the internet trolls we haven't talked
about them for a while you know a lot of
sites have been slowly banning the
anonymous comments YouTube as you guys
know I'm sure has been changing their
comments a lot of comments are
disappearing and getting spammed all
that kind of stuff The Huffington Post
has said they're gonna ban anonymous
comments although that hasn't happened
yet but an interesting study came out on
the trolls researchers at the University
of Manitoba investigated whether people
who engage in trolling are characterized
by personality traits that fall into the
so-called dark tetrad Machiavellianism
which is a willingness to manipulate and
deceive others narcissism which is
egotism and self-obsession and
psychopathy which is the lack of remorse
and empathy and finally sadism which is
the pleasure in the suffering of others
so the study found that these traits and
sometimes a combination of these traits
are something that the trolls as they
were I really wish there was a better
word for that seem to all or most have
Jimmy take it away what no is that a
study about those personality traits of
internet trolls or Catholic school
teachers because that's what it seemed
like that every Catholic school teacher
I had suffered from all of those things
it's a fine line it's a fine line yeah
you know what the thing about we are in
an increasingly impolite society right
it's brutal if you go to go to YouTube
pick any video you look at the fourth
comment or the fourth comment or always
burst lessly rips the third commenter
and then the fifth commenter extract the
peacemaker tries to find common ground
and for that he's rewarded by the six
commenter impugning his sexuality
there's basically like a decent
conversation for a little bit and then
it devolves into just everyone attacking
each other but is there some you know I
know it's easy to make fun of the trolls
and we do it all the time but is there
something healthy about it is there
something healthy about the ability to
anonymously just vent and then you can
still do this outward normal life but
that you get that [ __ ] out yeah no okay
because I don't think that's what
trolling is and by the way I think it's
a perfect word because I think in this
time where we're all so politically
correct and sensitive this we can
finally call something what it is this
hates
each by these people that don't feel
they have any other power or any other
outlet and any other way I think it's a
perfect word for it and if it wasn't if
it if it had a point and if it was
constructive it wouldn't be called
trolling so I don't know what the
healthy benefit of that is yeah and
maybe and that's why I don't I
do not read comments because I really
truly believe that if you like me or
hate me it really is none of my business
if I got rid of all the death threats
and rape fantasies and all of the
marriage proposals I would just go back
to me yeah so it doesn't matter I know
how big my boobs are I was born with
them I get it I know you know I'm so
glad you like them but I don't need you
to tell me about them so I I get it and
I just don't really see what the benefit
is of going on logging in burning
calories to actually do the work but I
don't know who's going on reading them
either when it comes to that could you
get as a community no you find that you
can get 20 good compliments and you're
like a Zippity do that but you get one
bad one am i under undercover name I've
several you have sir and you're
responding to these people and fighting
with them you know it sometimes does
that mean you have these traits I think
I might have some of them I think the
one positive thing that trolls do when
it's you know you'll see a guy and he'll
write something and then you're like oh
and then like I'll catch mine oh he's
he's goofing around
right it's guys just trying to get a
reaction and then it helps me take a
step back and see it as from okay so I'm
not too emotional I don't get it helps
me put actually does help me pull back
and kind of deal with these things in a
more rational way actually the whole
commenting or the whole idea of whatever
video I'm watching yeah so neither one
of you as the freedom lovers that I know
you are you don't want to get rid of
them them so despite everything you just
said you don't you think that it's a
perfectly fine thing to exist right I
just don't understand and and maybe it's
because it's too personal for you but I
don't understand how you are allowed to
do stuff like this anonymously I've
never understood that that I don't get
right so please take it away if you
understand it well what do you think
about the I mean people clearly wouldn't
do it right if it wasn't anonymous so do
you think you
should-should ban the anonymity uh-huh
you know that's tough III you know this
new thing that they've done were yet
with the Google+ enough I hate it yeah
and it you know it's it's actually
driven some people away from YouTube so
I think it's bad I think you just gotta
let people who gives a [ __ ] if you know
who the person is don't you know it's
just a comment this pass over it but you
don't think that that holds the person
doing it accountable it doesn't give
them another layer of maybe I'm not that
really that guy because for me I've
never really been one I can handle
myself I don't care it doesn't matter to
me and this has always been my problem
it's my poor mother
it's my poor family these people are
proud of me they want the best for me
they don't need to go to their you know
little organizations or their bank or
whatever and go look at what my
daughter's done google her name and see
like something horrible you know that I
can handle myself but I don't want to
put people who love me and who are much
sweeter than me through this that's
actually really funny there is a guy who
commented on a lot of our early videos
who used his avatar was a picture of
Bill O'Reilly and I think it said like
you know Bill O'Reilly 69 or something
and my mom called me and she said Bill
O'Reilly's been writing these crazy
sounds like but you got it yeah and I
said mom not you know sometimes they
fake you know but yeah you you made so
you wouldn't ban them you'd let him be
no I do what I like is made me I don't
know why made me think is home Jimmy but
like my you know you're my mother no
matter what they just don't understand
like your mom didn't understand that
it's not Bill O'Reilly yeah like I
remember when my uh my second Comedy
Central special aired and my mom and I
was like hey mom would really did well
it's about she's like oh great hopefully
somebody will see this and give you a
break like this is the goddamn break I
have a whole hour on television they're
giving me my whole hour to say whatever
the [ __ ] I want it's a big deal it
worked out all worked out somebody did
see me and they gave me a goddamn TV
show there you go people we are ending
this with a shout-out to Jimmy's
number-one troll his mother
that's that's really pretty great